Today, we're taking a look
at jaw breakers and gobstoppers,
and seeing what happens
if we heat them up,
melt them down,
rinse them away,
or just plain smash 'em.
[Music]
Most of you are probably
familiar with jawbreakers.
They're a round candy
that just has layers
and layers of color and flavor.
They come in a few
different varieties,
and we've got some things
we want to try out
with these bad boys.
This right here is just
over 2 inches in diameter.
It's pretty standard size
for a jawbreaker.
We've also got
this Mega jawbreaker,
which, oh boy,
feels quite a bit heavier
than our mid sized one.
And I can only imagine
that it would take months
to eat this whole thing.
Normally, when you're
eating a jawbreaker,
you're going to lick it,
and since it's made up almost
entirely sugar, flavor,
and coloring, it's going
to take a while to get through,
but you can get through it.
Rather than just sit here,
licking this jawbreaker forever,
I thought we would get
a little time lapse of something
a little bit faster.
We're going to
take this jawbreaker,
put it on a little stand,
and then have running
water flow down over it,
and just let that water run
until it just carves
away the jawbreaker.
Hopefully, we should be able
to see the different layers
as they're exposed,
and then washed away,
and we're a little curious
what shape we're going
to end up with.
[Music]
We've got our giant jawbreaker,
and you know what?
I just--
I want to cut it in half.
Now, if you're a big fan
of the channel What's Inside,
you may have seen
a few years ago,
they did cut one of these in half.
I wanted to try as well,
and then we're really
going to clean it up.
I want some really good shots
of what the inside of one
of these looks like.
So I've never cut one
of these in half.
They had quite
a hard time with it.
They use a chisel.
They ended up using
like a grinder to just cut
all the way around part of it,
and then break it in half.
I'm gonna see
if I can get through this whole
thing with a hacksaw.
I've never tried
this before though,
so I may have to improvise
if the hacksaw doesn't work.
Now, this is
our largest Jawbreaker.
It's pretty dang big.
It's about the size
of a softball,
and it weighs,
I believe, a pound,
which is a lot of candy.
I do kind of want to test
if you can actually break a jaw
with this Jawbreaker.
I have an idea.
Success.
This is now a verified,
well, Jaws breaker,
if not Jawbreaker.
[Music]
Okay, I think I've cut all the
way through this jawbreaker now.
It's sort of clicked together,
so at least half of it,
I think that means is separated.
I have a ton of this just
jawbreaker dust here,
and flakes just chipped
off the outside,
and I think I owe an apology
to the What's Inside team
because I thought it
was going to be easier
than it was,
and it was really weird.
It kept sticking to the saw.
I ended up having to just
wash the saw blade off
every like 30 seconds or so.
But that is super cool.
Okay.
I need to clean this up,
and make it just
really nice and pretty.
'Cause you can see
all of the layers,
but you can't see
them very well just
because of all the saw marks,
and the different
cutting angles and stuff.
So it looks good now,
we can make it better.
[Music]
As you can see, we've got lots
of these little ones.
These are called Gobstoppers,
or Everlasting Gobstoppers,
that's what they say on the box.
The name comes from
a Roald Dahl book called Charlie
and the Chocolate Factory.
In the book,
Everlasting Gobstoppers were
supposed to last forever.
You could suck on them.
They would change colors.
They would change flavors,
but they'd never go away.
Well, we haven't quite
figured out how to make
the Everlasting part.
Each one of these boxes says
it has about 9 servings,
and each serving is 9 pieces,
and that gives us about
81 Gobstoppers per box.
And if we're trying
for 1,000 Gobstoppers,
that's 12 and 1/2 boxes,
give or take.
And so, we are going
to load up 13 boxes,
so we might actually have just
over a thousand Gobstoppers.
Throw them on the barbecue.
Just your standard cookout food.
You know, some
people like chicken,
some people like steaks,
some people like Gobstoppers.
That should be just over
1,000 tiny little Jawbreakers.
We've got a tray full
of a thousand jawbreakers.
Let's go upstairs
where the barbecue is.
[Music]
We could put
another rack over here,
and put the whole pan
on top of that.
But where's the fun in that?
Let's go put the rack directly
onto the charcoal.
Here we go.
I've always really preferred
my jawbreakers to have
a good smoky flavor
to 'em, you know.
This is a good way to get that.
[Music]
Our 1,000 Gobstoppers
in the barbecue
have now been cooking
for maybe 15-20 minutes,
and they are mostly melted
away in just this soup
of molten jawbreaker candy.
Just turned a sort
of chocolatey raspberry color.
It's very thin.
Like I didn't think it
was going to get this thin,
but look how liquid that is.
[Music]
It's not terrible.
It has a really
interesting texture to it,
and it's not
something unexpected.
Even though it's smooth
at this point,
having been all melted down,
it still has a feel
as though it's slightly powdery,
like other compacted
powder candies, like Smarties
or something like that.
That would be the American
type of Smarties,
which are small
fruit flavored things,
and not the Canadian
or perhaps other types
of Smarties as well,
which are basically M&M's
under a different name.
So yeah, it tastes
like it doesn't--
I don't know.
I don't know
if it taste powdery is
the right way to say,
but it feels powdery.
I know I've licked this,
but I'm the only one
who's going to be eating it.
So I'm just gonna put it
right back here in the soup.
Keep mixing this up.
We have melted most
of what's in here.
Just trying to finish
off those last few sticklers
to really get this all liquid.
[Music]
There's just a lot
of burnt boiled
over sugar on the barbecue
down at the bottom.
I don't see any Gobstoppers
left in here.
So I'm going to say
that is thoroughly toasted
at this point.
[Music]
It's a lot like
a soft Starburst,
like a slightly warm Starburst.
That's about the texture.
Really sticks to my teeth a lot.
[Music]
It really is kind of just a mix
of all the different flavors,
like there's grape,
and orange, and lime,
and raspberry,
and whatever else is in those.
I think it's better to just
have individual flavors
than all mixed together,
but it's just sort of
a general fruit-flavored candy.
So sticky.
As an option
of something to show,
we did have some Gobstoppers
in a slow cooker.
However, we decided
that's pretty similar
to the look of the barbecue,
it's just on a smaller scale.
So we were going to turn it off,
but I discovered
something interesting.
The Gobstoppers,
even after sitting here
for like an hour and a half,
it barely changed shape at all.
But I did discover
that they've become soft
as they've heated up.
So now, we've got
squishy Gobstoppers,
and they are fairly hot,
but not so hot that it's
really hurting to hold them.
And so now, it's just--
Instead of jawbreakers,
they're just like a soft candy.
Out of all of
the jawbreaker tests
that we've tried out today,
this might be the one that I
recommend actually trying.
You definitely want
to be careful
that you're not going
to burn yourself on them,
but they're pretty good.
No broken jaws.
It's not known exactly
when jaw breakers were invented,
but they became popular
in the late 1800s
and early 1900s thanks to
the Ferrara Pan Candy Company.
Guys, that's not all.
We've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top is going
to take you to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
it will subscribe
you to our channel.
That way, you never gonna miss
out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.